hélas
[Musique]
schumi a présenté il ya quelques jours
en inde sa nouvelle marque c'est poko
phone avec un nouveau smartphone qui
s'appelle le f1 aujourd'hui vous avez le
lancement en grande pompe au palais
tokyo yoyo directement paris ce parce
que vous avez la fiche qui est juste là
on est plutôt pas mal pour ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va aller voir
directement sur place ce que vaut cette
marc paucot phone est ce que ce f1 est
aussi bien en tout cas que ce que j'ai
pu lire dans la presse par rapport à la
sortie romain 2 go
[Musique]
une vidéo aujourd'hui qui vous est
proposé avec un partenaire sur
l'événement c'est cross shopper pour en
parler au retour nos studios
pourquoi je vous parle de crançot peur
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai inclus crans
chopper dans cette vidéo parce que tout
simplement
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
une solution qui est différente de ce
qu'on peut trouver sur marché et qu' une
solution qui est hyper intéressante pour
vous puissiez acheter tous vos objets
notamment vos objets high tech a les
meilleures conditions parce que vous
allez pas avoir affaire à des offres qui
sont sélectionnés par un site mais bien
à une communauté réelle comme vous comme
moi qui va rechercher les meilleures
offres pour vous et ça ça fait toute la
différence
et en plus de ça c'est une entreprise
française alors je vous explique comment
ça marche vous voulez acheter un nouveau
smartphone vous n'avez pas envie de
passer des heures en ligne à rechercher
et c'est justement là dessus que cross
over intervient avec leur service est
vraiment super intéressant et je vais
vouloir rechercher un dernier smartphone
de chimie par exemple le shiro mis le
mil 8 g/t sur 30 chopper je suis allé au
606 d'un e-commerçant pour récupérer le
lien par exemple n'importe quel
commerçant je récupère le lien de la
fiche produit du 1008 jeu la copie colle
directement dans la barre de recherche 2
transf hopper et là j'ai valence ma
recherche
très rapidement il ya de nombreuses
personnes qui font la recherche pour moi
qu'ils vont trouver la meilleure offre
au meilleur prix je vous invite vraiment
et c'est parce que même si tout de suite
vous n'êtes pas dans un projet d'achat
immédiat donc vous dites baugé s'est
peut-être un jour vous invite vraiment
fait est tout de suite allé faire un
tour vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description vous allez sur cros chopper
vous simulez une recherche vous allez
voir franchement c'est bluffant
jamais venu ici c'est vraiment super
super classe comme lieu certes étoiles
est vraiment un spot incroyable
si vous perdez superbe salle ratant les
collègues on va se perdre
les streams sur la bonne voie
[Musique]
et là on va décider dans quelques jours
pour l'instant on va déjà regardé un
petit peu comment il ya présentation est
super cool fière d'être vraiment
vraiment puissant et ça c'est plutôt un
point extrêmement positif
c'est en tout cas tout ce qu'on attend
d'une seconde marque de la partition
mihocko est déjà si on me la qualité des
produits là je pense qu'avec ce
photophone d'un pays défier lors on va
le tester
pas forcément tout de suite probablement
dans les jours à venir je veux sortir
une vidéo test complet de ce produit en
attendant je trouve premières
impressions plutôt cool package est
plutôt sympa on discute un peu plus la
wii un peu plus de livres
ok donc excellente nouvelle regarder ce
que j'ai récupéré un peu de matos
forcément j'ai hop un très joli t-shirt
francophones comme ça j'ai peur mes
billets merci beaucoup poko phone et
puis surtout surtout le plus important
dans l'histoire c'est franchement le
smartphone on va le tester
peut-être demain peut-être demain si
vous êtes sympas en tête faire un petit
test est une globale version on va déjà
commencer un petit peu regardez un peu
comment il est foutu à l'intérieur ça
peut être super cool up déjà au louvre
hop c'est vrai qu'il est quand même
classe
je vais pas tout de suite tout de suite
le dénuder en termes de prise en main je
trouve plutôt cool smartphone assez
compact vous avez ici les boutons pour
le monter le volume le bc l'allumer
au-dessus la prise jack 3.5 ça c'est
franchement génial prise micro ici de
l'usb type c'est qu'une recharge rapide
haut parleurs sous le bas vous avez du
haut parleur mono les haut-parleurs
stéréo là-dessus top caméra 20
mégapixels à l'avant c'est la même
caméra que vous avez sur le 1008 vous
avez une caméra 2 mégapixels ici c'est
une sony mx360 3 c'est exactement la
même que sur 1008 une caméra samsung 5
mégapixels qui me servira pour l'effet
de profondeur lorsque voulait faire des
modes portrait et bien sûr de
l'intelligence artificielle de la
reconnaissance de scène enfin tout ça on
va le développer un peu plus tard vous
allez pas franchement c'est super cool
est ce qu a voulu mettre en avant
vraiment là-dessus poco phone c'est
vraiment la puissance c'est vraiment là
dessus qu'ils sont battus et vraiment
qu'ils ont mieux faire plus complet ils
ont aujourd'hui quand même pris l'oeuf
la dragonne le qualcomm snapdragon 845
qui est aujourd'hui le plus puissant sur
le marché couplé avec un refroidissement
liquide pour avoir une vraie répartition
la température ça vous permet d'avoir
des performances complètement optimisé
et ça franchement c'est super cool
au niveau géographique vous avez une
adreno 630 vous avez surtout une énorme
batterie cap millan terreur et ça aussi
c'est un excellent point de la recharge
rapide 3.06 gigaoctets de ram 64 j
allais stockage ou 128 giga de stockage
vous avez soit un dos en polycarbonate
soit un dos en fibre de carbone c'est
une édition un peu plus exceptionnel il
appelle le armor aide edition qui pour
l'instant n'est pas encore dispo sur le
marché windows sera bientôt pas d'info
sur leurs sorties
raddas trou mais ça ne saurait tarder et
là le vent se lève quand je mange micro
ça va me rendais bien quoique malouines
troy celui là donc je vous disait il à
son script qui parle ça la route et louf
vous avez une finition 3d incurvé sur le
côté un écran corning gorilla glass à
l'avant un écran de 6,18 pouces ce n'est
pas dû aux led c'est du lcd
on va le tester demain donc demain ou
après demain vous allez voir donc à mon
avis franchement ça paraît quand même le
faire tout le produit est vraiment dispo
un tarif super intéressante vous avez
pas entre eux en configuration si j'y
garde 64 giga de ram à 329 euros et
hansi giga de ram plus 128 go de
stockage à 369 euros
c'est franchement pas cher pour avoir un
smartphone avec un qualcomm snapdragon
845 refroidissement liquide 'notre et
non 60 entre si je garde un drame du
stockage c'est franchement un smartphone
qui est extrêmement bien payé et c'est
là où on voit vraiment l'intérêt et la
stratégie qui a été développée par
chamonix en créant cette marc paucot
phone ça peut pour en faire une
concurrence par rapport à huawei qui a
créé au nord chez omi a maintenant 100
poko phone permet d'avoir des sous
marques avec des produits low cost mais
avec des performances techniques
complètement incroyable ça à mon avis ça
va faire beaucoup de bruit surtout
premier produit le vent aidant les
autres qu'ils vont payer par la suite
et franchement franchement je pense
qu'on va voir belle surprise il a plein
d'autres choses côté mis en avant par la
marque notamment le fait d'avoir un
facebook en infrarouge en infrarouge ça
vous permet de causes pour non-paiement
de déverrouiller la nuit vous me direz
la nuit n'a pas dit quand vous êtes dans
votre pieux le soir que la lumière est
coupée vous avez la reconnaissance en
infrarouge ça marche plutôt bien il ya
un poc été mis en avant par coco phone
c'est vraiment le fait de dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui prend par exemple une
capture d'écran de votre visage qu'il
imprime ne pourra pas dire houllier il
faut vraiment que ce soit votre tronche
il ya eu plusieurs démos de fait bon à
tester effectivement mais en tout cas ça
ferait quand même plutôt intéressant
mais vraiment tout à côté aussi au
niveau de l'eau est contaminée jours ci
un 1008 pour coco qui a vraiment été
créés sans avoir parlé lors des phases
de tests et en tout cas voilà moi je
trouve que ce smartphone est plutôt
couleurs ce qu'on va faire c'est que là
je ne les pas des balles et on va le
hunt boxer sur ma chaîne addiktv donc
vous invite à me rejoindre sur instagram
monsieur underscore heureux comme ça on
va le boxer on va regarder sans relâche
dans la boîte directement là bas et qui
vous donnent rendez vous
1 ou dans les jours à venir sur youtube
pour continuer à parler de ce produit on
va le tester on va beaucoup tester les
caméras on va regarder la puissance on
va installer déjà un petit peu gourmand
dessus et on va voir au final c'est
pourquoi défunt est vraiment vraiment
une bête de compet comme le montre tout
cas la marque dans ce cas moi je trouve
plutôt cool mais qu'est ce que tu fais
quand il faire voyager et que tu as à
plein de smartphones est beau tu te
démerdes par la vie pour que tu tiennes
sinon c'est bien
restez connectés parce qu'on va tester
aussi aux us les iphone mac pro on va
tester le plus les fon x aussi très
prochainement et là on a des sur le coco
phone en plus ça ira mal de choses qui
vont arriver ça c'est plutôt cool qu'ils
ont l'impression d'avoir une valise de
receleurs avec plein de smartphones a
testé à l'intérieur c'est juste énorme
ballon les gars verdict c'était comment
cette présentation va très très bien on
a vu le vrai monde
ouais vous avez une vraie faut dire que
tu sais on a vu le poke au fond comment
vous le trouvez le propofol oui bien
pour rapport qualité-prix wendel world
rapide avant plus que le mois le plus il
dit d'après ce que j'ai compris avec
christian d'avoir confort et riffier
insérer ces vérités un coup là-bas merci
les gars ok c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
alors je vous laisse avec le palais
tokyo en fond derrière je vous donne
rendez vous dès demain parce que demain
on va tester un nouveau smartphone je
sais pas encore lequel je me tâte je me
tâte peut-être les pokémon et fera
peut-être leur iphone et x peut-être un
autre peut-être qu'on va parler
carrément de tout autre chose en tout
cas soyez sûr que demain 28 avoir un
sujet est super intéressant et puis
après demain on part à berlin on sera
directement ensemble à l'ifa avec plein
de nouvelles choses doit y avoir des
conférences de asus acer va ya voir sony
va y avoir du samsung va y avoir lgv
rhin-rhône en dira pas mal de choses on
va en parler ensemble dont je vais pas
faire une seule chose c'est rester
connectés et pour les soigner
[Musique]